we're talking about these funny hand
warmers in the shape of a heart and each
one contains a liquid and a little metal
clicker and the point is that this can
generate quite high temperatures which
will keep your hand warm inside is
sodium acetate that is dissolved in
water it's a very concentrated solution
sodium acetate is made up of ions
positively charged sodium negatively
charged acetate positive and negative
attract each other and so you need
energy to pull them apart and you have
to imagine a huge array of these
millions and billions of these going
alternately positive negative and so on
but I can't afford that amount of model
so I press it down and there we go if I
look at it on the screen you can see a
blob of warmth coming in the middle of
the heart the other heart doesn't do
anything and it reaches in oh it's
really getting warm and it goes up to a
temperature of about 50 degrees it's
somehow producing crystals that come out
sideways and giving out heat which lasts
for 20 minutes or so what happens is
when you click a tiny particle of
something is released some people say
it's a bit of metal others say it's a
tiny crystal of sodium acetate that was
trapped on the metal surface but it
doesn't matter you release something and
as soon as you have that first kindly
nucleus the precipitation takes place
and you can see the crystals spreading
out across the hand warmer and the
temperature rising
so when you drop crystals of sodium
acetate into water they ions separate
and because they need energy the
temperature of the water drops and you
can see quite nicely with thermal
imaging
if you drop sodium acetate crystals into
water the water gets cuddle
it's getting cold because some of the
thermal energy the heat energy in the
water is being used to pull these ions
apart this is a physical change so if
they come out of solution reform their
crystals
you'll get that energy back so the
question is how can you get that energy
back in your hand warmer the way you've
got to do it is to get as much sodium
acetate as possible dissolved in the
water and with sodium acetate if you
heat the water up
you can dissolve more and more of the
salt so if you go almost to the boiling
point of water hundred degrees
centigrade you can dissolve really a
large amount what you would imagine that
if you dissolve all this stuff up by
heating it as soon as you cooled it down
you would expect it all to come out
again but the interesting thing is that
crystals cannot just form in a really
clean solution they need to have tiny
particles doesn't really matter what of
tiny bit of metal a tiny crystal to form
round it's rather like a crowd forming
round a single person it has to have
something to start it so if you have a
really clean filtered solution if you
cool it down the sodium acetate stays in
solution and that's what's inside your
hand warmer so at least your hands will
be warm when you walk to work in the
freezing conditions
to reuse the hand warmer you have to
heat it up again so we dropped it into
boiling water and quite by chance we
noticed that there were all sorts of
interesting bubbles and vortices in the
surface of the boiling water so that's
what you have to do to finish it off
just put it in there leave it for a
little while you take it out and let it
relax and it gets cooled down and
remains liquid and if you heat it for a
longest time all the sodium acetate
re-dissolve
and then if you cool it slowly it will
be ready to use again the problem is
that if you don't heat it long enough
and leave just one or two tiny crystals
it can go off spontaneously and suddenly
release its heat it's not dangerous but
it means when you go to it to warm your
hands you'll find it's fired already
thanks for watching this video and we'd
like to thank Google's making and
science team for making it possible if
you'd like to see more of the videos
they've helped create there's a
brilliant playlist there's links on the
screen and in the description also if
you'd like to see professor polyakov's
long-awaited appearance on my
objectivity series there are also links
for that and we'll be back again soon
with more videos with the thermal
imaging camera